we've made a lot of MacPro videos in the
last month and the one thing that was
consistent between all of them were all
of the comments about AMD's new thread
Ripper CPUs and how you can build a much
cheaper PC that's also much more
powerful so we did just that this right
here is our $5,000 thread Ripper PC and
in this video we're going to compare it
to our $15,000 Mac Pro in everything
from features benchmarks thermals fan
noise real world performance and more
now as a disclaimer I do want to mention
that this isn't a fair comparison in
many ways one big one being that the Mac
Pro uses Mac OS which is important for a
lot of people and at this point you
can't even hackintosh this thread Ripper
there are also a few ways that the Mac
Pro absolutely kills this PC build and
we'll mention all of these important
factors at the end of this video when
choosing the parts for this thread River
PC I wanted to make sure to match as
much specs as possible which required an
eight hundred and fifty dollar
motherboard that comes jam-packed with
features so before we get into the
performance testing here's how the
features of this PC compare to the Mac
Pro it comes with Wi-Fi six built in
compared to apples Wi-Fi five it comes
with PCI Express 4 compared to three on
the Mac and just like the Mac Pro it
comes with dual 10 Gigabit Ethernet and
it also supports ECC Ram although we
didn't use it for this build
it comes with much more i/o including 10
USB 8 ports seven of which support Gen 2
speeds compared to just two ports on the
Mac Pro that only support Gen 1 speeds
this PC build also has two USB sea ports
and two Thunderbolt 3 ports compared to
8 Thunder both 3 ports on the Mac Pro
configuration along with that the
motherboard in this PC comes with a
bonus add-in storage card which can raid
up to four PCI Express 4.0 m2 SSDs
together for a massive 15,000 megabyte
per second read speed you can also
easily add in a ton of different storage
like hard drives which isn't always easy
or cheap on the Mac Pro and the best
feature of all is that this PC build can
power Apple's 6 K Pro X er display in
ten bit at 6k resolution will show you
how we did that in just a minute here's
a list of all of the parts we use for
this PC build compared to the parts that
are in the Mac Pro and we have links
down in the video description as well
now if you want to know why we chose
these specific parts we discussed them
in our step-by-step build guide that you
guys can watch after this video to learn
how you yourself can build this PC one
of the major annoyances we ran into with
the Mac Pro is the Apple controls all of
the driver updates for the graphics
cards forcing users to wait until the
update Mac OS but with Windows part
manufacturers can update their drivers
on their own schedule so you get updates
much more often now getting into
performance we wanted to point out a
massive advantage for the PC and that's
the ability to overclock which you can't
do on the Mac Pro this setup is capable
of overclocking up to 4.25 gigahertz but
it draws an extra 180 watts of power and
puts out way more heat and fan noise for
only 8% more performance so we went back
to stock for this comparison so without
further ado let's start out with
performance testing with Geekbench 5 CPU
tests unsurprisingly this 32 quartz
retro CPU scored over 2 times the
multi-core performance of our 12 core
Mac Pro but be sure to keep in mind that
it only costs 42% more while getting
over double the performance which is an
awesome bang for the buck
now we don't usually mention single core
performance but it shocked us that this
PC got a higher single core score even
though it has 20 more cores which
usually never happened so ultimately
you're not sacrificing performance for
tasks that only used one core one
benefit for the 12th core Xeon is that
it supports up to 768 gigabytes of RAM
compared to only 256 on this threader
for CPU but to be honest not that many
people actually need that much RAM now
moving on to Cinebench r20 which pushes
all of these course to their max the
thread River performs even better
scoring 17250 for points compared to
only 5519 on the mac pro however it came
at a cost of fan noise even though this
case is a dark bass pro 900 from be
quiet which is filled with sound
dampening materials and
very quiet fans the ambient noise in the
middle of our office these that are on
37 to 38 decibels loud the back of the
threader abruzzi while idling measures
at around 46 to 47 decibels and while
running sediments are 20 it measured all
the way up to 55 decibels loud in
contrast the macro idled at around 38
decibels which is basically completely
silent and after many runs of sand much
r20 it measured slightly higher at
around 39 decibels much lower than the
pc at idle and the most annoying thing
about this PC is that the fans kick up
pretty loud
every time you open up a new app or
change settings even sometimes in the
web browser just because of how much
wattage it pushes to the CPU and even
with this much performance we noticed
that Mac OS is still much snappier than
Windows 1 doing basic tasks and doing
things like installing programs and
unzipping files which is why a lot of
people prefer Mac's for example we had
apps freeze multiple times on this PC
just in the time that we're doing this
test and absolutely zero freezes or
issues with the Mac Pro running Mac OS
in terms of temps while running cinnamon
jar 20 the Mac Pro got up to 69 degrees
while the thread repair PC reached a
high of 79 degrees which is still very
impressive thanks to the massive water
cooling system but it did have to run at
full blast to keep it at 79 degrees now
moving on to graphics benchmarks we
tested Geekbench 5 using metal on the
Mac Pro and CUDA on the PC which is the
best case scenario for both systems here
the PC scored over 50% higher than the
Mac Pro which is impressive considering
the fact that you can get it for around
a thousand 250 compared to paying Apple
$2,400 for the Vega to upgrade so with
that we decided to test out gaming
performance using the unison heaven
benchmark on the extreme preset and the
PC got 210 frames per second compared to
a hundred and fourteen on the Mac Pro
and even with that much fps the twenty
atti graphics card in the PC stayed at a
cool 70 degrees thanks to its triple
slot cooler the Mac Pro's mega to GPU
Rihanna 81 degrees but the difference
was that it stayed completely silent
throughout the test in fact even when we
max
the CPU and the GPU at the same time by
running cinnamon jar 20 and Unigine
heaven simultaneously they remained
basically silent which is incredibly
impressive we also tested graphics card
rendering in the blender benchmark and
the thread rubber PC finished the BMW M
classroom test in only three minutes and
eight seconds compared to 15 minutes and
54 seconds on the Mac Pro but that
wasn't Mac West we're graphics rendering
is new for blender and it seems to not
be optimized as a weaker AMD GPU was
much faster under windows since the
species motherboard supports PCI Express
4 we took advantage of it with a
super-fast one terabyte m2 SSD which got
read speeds to a massive 4995 megabytes
per second compared to 29.92 on the Mac
Pro and 4 write speeds the PC got 4257
compared to 2948 on the Mac Pros one
terabyte SSD this is something you won't
be able to get on the Mac Pro from a
single storage drive because the 2019
Mac Pro is forever limited to PCI
Express 3.0 which is a bummer now moving
on to photo editing and Lightroom the
thread Ripper does an amazing job in
terms of editing smoothness as does the
Mac but when exporting 542 megapixel
edited RAW images it's only 42 percent
faster than the Mac Pro instead of over
300% faster in Cinebench even though all
32 cores were being maxed outs which is
quite a surprise this show is that
having so many extra cores doesn't
necessarily mean that it will scale in
real-world usage now before we get into
video editing performance where we start
to see a very different trend in results
I want to review how we were able to get
this thread river PC to power apples 6k
Pro display XDR we did it by installing
a very special dual Thunderbolt 3 port
add-in card which uses two DisplayPort
imports from your graphics card to
create tooth and about three ports which
we use to connect the display this
allows us to not only use the pro
display XDR but to get it working both
at 10 bit and 6k resolution which is
really impressive seeing as it's a
custom Windows PC and running AMD
processors now finally let's get into
video editing where we
with Premiere Pro because it's by far
the most used program the PC does a good
job putting the threader pert and NVIDIA
GPU to use but so does the mac pro with
metal at times I did notice a smoothness
difference in favor of the Mac because
if PC would drop frames at times when I
start playback or when scrubbing through
the timeline when it came time to export
regular 4k the Mac Pro surprisingly took
the lead even though both systems were
not maxing out the CPU or the graphics
this is where optimizations start coming
in and apples metal API starts to kick
in if you're somebody that works with
HEV see footage the Mac Pro is way
better here scrubbing on the timeline is
much smoother and exports our test
project almost three times faster this
is because the Mac Pro has apples t2
chip which greatly speeds up encoding
and they're only computer that doesn't
have it the five key iMac takes about
the same time as this thread Ripper
stabilization is also faster with a Mac
Pro which is really weird since the PCs
single core speed is actually faster so
maybe it's just Mac OS now for some
positives playing back tough c200
footage is much smoother on the threader
/ at about 45 frames per second compared
to 24 on the Mac Pro this is because
premiere isn't optimized and doesn't use
graphics like Final Cut or resolve so
the extra 20 cores comes in pretty handy
exporting this graded 4k 60 project is
more than twice as fast with a PC
because it is all CPU based so if you
work with this footage in Premiere Pro
you want as much course as you can
possibly get your hands on now such on
resolve which is much more optimized in
general and makes way more use of the
graphics than CPU cores I started with a
famous candle benchmark that tests the
video editing performance of the GPUs
and surprisingly both graphics cards
performed exactly the same reaching 18
frames per second while being maxed out
next we D noise 4k Blackmagic Raw and
the results were exactly the same
running between 22 and 24 frames per
second showing us that even though the
28 de ti is much more powerful for
gaming and other tasks for video editing
the Vega 2 paired with Apple's metal API
really holds its own
editing smoothness and resolve is
excellent for both and exports are much
faster than premier sometimes even
beating out final cut
there are also some advantages with
Windows which does allow the graphics
card to encode the video and the latest
version of resolve uses Nvidia graphics
to decode read raw allowing for perfect
full a.k playback without needing a 28
or 32 core CPU now resolve has these
exact features ready for Mac OS as well
and the next version should enable them
our Mac Pro also has a big advantage you
can't get with any other computer and
that is the afterburner card which
completely takes the load off of the CPU
for pro res and pro res Raw allowing
even an a core CPU to playback six
streams of ek ProRes Ralph footage where
this beastly 32 core would only handle
three and the best 28 core mac pro
without afterburner would only handle -
there are so much more differences in
terms of video editing and each system
has its strong points but to properly
show you guys we need to make a
dedicated video so if you guys want to
see that use the link in the video
description after this one is over now
while it seems that this $5000 thread
Ripper PC totally blows away our $15,000
Mac Pro and it definitely does in
certain tasks there are a few things
that the Mac Pro has that this PC simply
cannot get and a cool bonus feature that
the PC has first off you can get up to
seven hundred sixty eight gigabytes of
RAM in this mac pro or 1.5 terabyte so
with the higher spec CPUs significantly
higher than the 256 gig on this PC the
case is also very unique making it
incredibly easy to work on unlike the
pretty complicated case we used on this
Red River PC and the Mac Pro also offers
incredibly silent workflows whereas the
thread Ripper is honestly annoying to
work by even after tuning the fans and
using this case designed to lower noise
the Mac Pro also offers eight Thunder
both reports with the ability to have 12
which you simply cannot get on any PC
and the last big difference is the
workstation grade parts and more
expensive components in general even
though we bought a really nice
motherboard Apple's offers way more
as far as PCI and the power supply can
actually handle for Vega two graphics
cards along with that thread Ripper CPUs
don't naturally compete with Zeon's that
would be AMD's epic line which costs
more and actually run slower on top of
that the mega 2 graphics is also a
workstation grade card and gets 32
gigabytes of ultra-fast HBM to memory
compared to only 11 on the 28 ETI which
will help a lot and tasks that use a lot
of VRAM to be comparable we would need
at least a quadrille r-tx 6000 which by
itself would nearly double our build
price while still being short 6 gigs of
memory and the memory is 30% slower than
HBM 2 but not everybody needs those
things for their work along with that
the macro comes completely ready to go
out of the box you just plug it in and
you're off whereas with a thread Ripper
build it took us a while to find all the
parts make sure everything's compatible
get it in took us a full day to get a
built in set up and optimized and for
some people if you have issues or you're
not good at it it might take you a
couple of days and those companies up a
couple of days could be worth thousands
of toddlers if you are a professional so
there definitely is value in having a
system that is just ready to go now not
everybody needs these things I just
mentioned and in those cases you can get
much more bang for the buck and more
upgrade ability with the windows thread
Ripper PC and our thread Ripper has one
other advantage built in wireless
charging on the top of the case so there
you guys have it
that was our $5,000 thread over BC
compared to our $15,000 Mac Pro if you
want to see a detailed video editing
comparison follow the link in the
description and if you want to see how
we built it check out that video right
there for our step-by-step guide and
click the circle above to subscribe if
you haven't already thanks for watching
and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]